hot breath you know how long did they
take you
into your career before you felt like oh
i'm starting to
at least get the hang of this or start
to sound like i want a sound
it took a while it was like there's like
a few jokes you're like oh that's like
what i
kind of who i kind of am you know
there's a few of those jokes that were
like
what i liked and what i want to sound
like and it's like it definitely takes
you a while to catch up to your tastes
in comedy you're like well that's you're
just doing like
some weird impression of what you want
to sound like you're not you yet
you know so it takes you a while to
really
from a distance like your act maybe like
you're close enough to not
but it's you have to have some sort of
delusion to stay in it that young early
you know anyway so you probably have
similar delusion about your act that
you're not as bad as you think you are
yeah so that it keeps you in on a lot of
levels but yeah i definitely
it took me a while to be happy with it
you see like eight ten years
like i'd say like seven or eight seven i
remember
i was down here and i won the festival
down here and oh yeah the skull fest and
i
that's when i started to think that i
had like a couple that i'm like
i'm getting somewhere it wasn't like oh
wow my jokes are great
it was like oh i have a few that i think
these are i'm on the right track
i remember even when i won it i thought
this guy tom simmons had a better set
than me
no that's a weird that's a weird feeling
when you're like well i won
but and i know i you know you don't
usually feel that way because
you get everything later than you think
you deserve it
that's just how it goes in comedy like
so few comics
and the comics that pop off early
usually stink you know because this is
something that
take it just does take a long time to
get good at this is not there's a couple
exceptions but
it's something that does take so long
that when you get it too early
it's usually a fluke it's usually
because not because you put out a great
special it's because you
got something else like you want some tv
show and that's why you got it
so
when you do actually i mean i don't
think i did my first late nights that's
like eight and a half years in or
something so
was that conan yeah is that your first
and then since you've done colbert
and conan multiple times yeah any others
is that i've done conan i think four
times and
colbert once